the 2023 award season has descended upon
Tinseltown and that means the globe
weighs with baited breath for the 95th
academy awards ceremony it's approaching
quickly and we have a packed 10 picture
nominations stacking up with questions
such as will the Juggernaut Blockbuster
top gun Maverick take home best picture
or will everything everywhere all at
once keep the Western Front quiet or you
could have Elvis have it all the other
contenders All Shook Up hello everyone
my name is Mark Ellis and welcome to the
after show or as we call it this time of
year how to win your 2023 Awards ballot
that's right we're looking at going a
perfect 23 for 23 or at least helping
you win your Oscar pull mom this is the
year I'm doing it I say it every year on
this show it hasn't happened yet I'm
gonna defeat my mom in our Oscar pool
because I have two of the best in the
biz when it comes to predicting the
Oscars and they're certainly passionate
about their picks Nikki Novak and Scott
Mance are joining us here hello welcome
I'm so passionate I'm so excited my
heart is pounding right now I who cares
about the Super Bowl that intro is
award-worthy
that was amazing I thought you were
gonna say instead of All Shook Up I
thought you were gonna say thank you
very much but that's okay
don't have the best Elvis impression but
if the Oscar
Oscar looking for a host for next year
is available y'all crush your picks just
about every year and so here's how I
want to tee everyone up who's watching
at home on their streaming device
whether you're at the gym whether you're
dry well you shouldn't be driving you
should be the passenger Nikki I'll start
with you why should everybody watching
this vid trust your yeah well I wonder
why I'm an expert on gold Derby I quite
frequently win that now my big claim to
fame was the year that La La Land was
upset by Moonlight the big snafu the
biggest shock in Oscar history who was
the one person that predicted Moonlight
was going to win best picture
okay and La La Land was I don't even
know if anybody was predicting that but
I'm not going to rest on my Laurels this
year in predicting the best picture
nominees 10 slots I predicted all 10
correctly I was the only expert on gold
Derby to do that wow okay so even the
nominations we're knocking out of the
stadium Scott Vance I know you had a
Affinity of some sort for La La Land and
so that way
a lot of people missed that one what is
your pedigree and why should the folks
maybe trust you over the wonderful Nicki
first of all did it hurt it still hurts
it's still smart I look Nikki your your
credentials are very very impressive but
you were looking at a two-time gold
Derby oscar-winning champion because
last year at two years before that I was
the gold Derby champion last year I got
one wrong out of 23 two years before
that the year that I predicted that
parasite would win best picture Best
Director original screenplay and
international feature I got 22 right out
of 24. but wait there's more the year
that Spotlight won best picture I called
that over the Revenant and the year that
green book won best picture I called
that For Better or Worse
I I know what I'm talking about and I
could also tell you what days it was a
little obvious at that no it was not it
was not I'm not going to give you that
one the rest of them I will give you
green book was a surprise but parasite
not so much what was still team 1917. I
was left
already flowing here and this coming
from a guy who's still upset that
Shakespeare and love beat out Saving
Private Ryan
we're gonna get up for grabs here and
Nikki and Scott are going to walk you
through their decisions and what they
think is going to take home an Oscar
statue and then if there has to be a tie
breaker between the two I'll let you all
know my feelings on it take that with a
grain of salt these two are the pepper
in the dish and Scott I do want to ask
you before we get into the individual
categories overall this Oscar ceremony
that we're having we don't necessarily
know all of the winners of the various
award shows leading up to the Oscars at
the time of this taping we still have
the Director's Guild of America to go
the PGA The Producers Guild those are
some nice indicators as to how Academy
voters might be leaning but when you
look at the ceremony as a whole what
stands out to you what's a race that you
think could get really spicy well I'll
tell you uh best actress up until very
very recently it was looking like that
race was going to be a lock I'm not
going to say who that lock is yet
because that's going to be a
conversation that's probably going to be
the highlight of this conversation but
then that got thrown into a let's just
say there was a big Ranch deck I've
thrown into that machine which now makes
that category gory sort of up between
not one not two but three people also
there is best picture because if there's
one big huge takeaway from the Academy
Award nominations this year it's that
big movies are back four of those Best
Picture nominees made over 100 million
dollars
one of them well two of them made over
one billion and one of them made over
two billion and still counting Avatar
the way of water and out of those 10
best picture nominees only one of them
is exclusive to a streaming service so
the academy has spoken the year after
Coda became the first movie for a
streaming service to win and it was not
Netflix it was Apple TV plus the Oscar
is saying you know what we are in the
movie making business movies belong on
the big screen and here you go well a
lot of Blockbusters have been nominated
for some of the most prestigious Awards
Nikki is there a category is there an
actor and actress a performer director
somebody behind the scenes you're
keeping your eye on for a particularly
competitive category there's a couple I
agree with you on Best Actress but I
think the heated one is best actor I
think that's even more intriguing I
think it's a three-way race as far as
best picture goes I concur with you I
was still hoping the Batman got
nominated I was hoping that uh wakanda
forever we get nominated and we would
have more Blockbusters nominated because
if there is a year that I'm hoping a big
Blockbuster wins this picture it's this
year that said I don't know if that's
gonna happen we will get into that later
but the other one that I have my eye on
that I think is a two-way race at this
point is best director and I think best
director is going to be very very
interesting this year and will be a huge
indicator of what is going to win best
picture sometimes it's been split in
past years I don't know this year if one
of the nominees wins I think it's done
with it they win the DGA it's done I I
agree completely see this is why you
want all three of us at your Oscar party
Nikki and Scott for the picks and I'm
happy to run out and get it halfway
through the ceremony so we're gonna get
going here but a friendly reminder that
you can find your Oscar's ballot at
rottentomatoes.com or you can check out
the description of this vid for your own
ballot sharpen that pencil make sure
it's number two we don't really care it
could be number three
let's get it's not the S80 yeah we
already did those and uh I'm not gonna
tell you what my score was hopefully
Nikki and Scott have better results with
their Oscar pull this year let's get
into it with our first category we're
highlighting today best supporting
actress a supporting actress an actress
in a supporting role Scott Mance I go to
you first who's taking home the gold
okay this I think is close to a lock 95
there Angela Bassett for black panther
wakanda forever see most people think
that Angela Bassett already has an Oscar
for playing Tina Turner and What's Love
Got to Do With It which came out in
1993. she was nominated for it she did
not win that was her only other
nomination until this supporting actress
nomination for wakanda forever she is a
legend and she to me I'm just going to
say was by far the best thing about
wakanda forever I thought that movie was
really slow for the first half even
though it got better in the second half
but I remember watching that at the
premiere at the Dolby Theater you know
we were all there thinking she is giving
a performance that is above and beyond
what this movie really deserves and like
she should get nominated now she's gonna
win she's got the nomination she got the
winning Scott Manson's eyes how about
Nikki Novak and it would be the first
time a Marvel actor won at all at the
Academy Awards throwing a little bit
more juice in there I think this one is
a lock I agree it's Angela Bassett I
don't even think you need to watch the
film to know she was Best Supporting
Actor you can watch the trailer because
her moment her Oscar moment she doesn't
have a lot of screen time but it is in
the darn trailer and sometimes it's
accessibility this isn't a highly
nominated movie but people know that
performance it was a Powerhouse
performance everything everywhere all at
once is the only other movie that could
give some competition to Angela Bassett
but you do have a vote split you have
Stephanie Shu nominated Jamie Lee Curtis
she is also also a legend that has never
won but I do believe that the academy is
going to go with the legend they're
going to go with Angela Bassett for the
fact that she did not win for What Love
Got to Do with it and I think Stephanie
she will get the younger voters
nominating for her and Jamie Lee Curtis
will split with the older voters so I
think it is going to be Angela Bassett
all right so maybe a makeup call some 30
years later well I mean so you see how
easy my job is it's so congenial here
nobody's arguing yeah we all agree and I
will add my vote to that foreign
and so now let's quickly move on to
actor in a supporting role Nikki I'll
let you tee this one up okay well while
I think this one is the biggest lock I
do also want to add in something to
think about and chew on for people
filling out their ballot kihua Quan I
think is going to win for everything
everywhere all at once he's won every
single precursor up to this point
everybody knows this is a Redemption
story this is the story sometimes it's
the narrative about an actor and if
there is a lovable human being that has
come out of this award season I think
last year it might have been Troy kotzer
this year it is key you cannot help but
fall in love with him you watch his
speeches when he wins you truly feel the
pain of all of the years that this young
man who was Short Round in Indiana Jones
did not work was doing behind the scenes
stunt work he is having his moment he is
a lot he's been wanting everything he's
been nominated for so far up to this
point he is a a lovely human being I
feel like I was really lucky to have
seen that movie everything everywhere at
its World premiere on opening night at
South by Southwest last March I had to
see that movie go this distance to be
nominated for 11 Academy Awards and you
know his performance I remember thinking
when I saw it in March going like wow
he's really good like he stood out in a
film I agree that that is a very busy
movie like everything everywhere is a
whole lot to take in but he stood out
and that's another reason why he
deserves to win he did action he did the
heart of it he did the humor he did a
lot so let's give him credit it's not
just the narrative it's the performance
it's probably not the last time I make
this joke but he did everything
everywhere yeah he truly did well done
well done let's move on to our next
category which is original screenplay
Scott I'm gonna tennis it right back to
you could this be the first category
where you and Nikki don't see eye to eye
uh I'm guessing this one's going to go
to everything everywhere because if
you're if you're looking at uh an
original screenplay that screams
original it's pretty much everything
everywhere and the movie you know was
nominated for best picture and the best
directors for the Daniels and I just
think there's obviously a lot of love
for this movie and I think that as far
as screenplays go original screenplays
this doesn't get any more original than
this film yeah and you and I agree I
actually ran I wasn't sure if we were
going to both have the uh the same pick
for this but you look at winners like
get out they love originality they love
something like that they also tend to
award movies that also the screenplay
goes hand in hand with best picture it
is the current quote-unquote front
runner for best picture you look at
green book one for best screenplay that
wasn't the best screenplay but it went
on to win best picture you also look at
Coda wasn't necessarily in my opinion a
lot of people's opinion when that one
for screenplay everybody knew best
picture was over for sure last year so I
definitely think everything everywhere
all at once if you can picture that
movie without the screenplay you have
nothing oh absolutely yeah completely
yeah you have nothing but you do have
everything too I mean I could have gone
right there so I'm not the comedian I
make the obvious joke I mean these are
all pretty obvious picks as far as where
Scott and Nikki and where you are
watching at home should go with these
first three categories let's move to
adapted screenplay Nikki any surprises
here this one's a little bit tricky I
think this one's a little bit more open
but I did go with women talking this is
Sarah Pauley she had not been nominated
if the film had not been nominated in
best picture category which some people
thought it might not some people when
they when they're you know there's like
seven or eight really obvious Best
Picture nominees that wasn't one but
when it got that you know ninth or tenth
slot people are thinking because it was
the only other nomination it got I think
it's look it's wordy they love wordiness
they love something that's just
brilliantly written this could have been
a play or was you know it was but the
way that Sarah people love Sarah Paulie
that's the other thing about her if you
follow her on Twitter she's hilarious
she's irreverent and I think people are
going to want uh to award her here well
listen Sarah Polly is an amazing writer
this is her second nomination for a
screenplay she was nominated for 2007's
away from her first this category
adapted screenplay the fact that you
have a movie called Top Gun nominated
for screenplay I think that's pretty
freaking awesome if you're asking me
what's my favorite uh what was the word
thing are you hope I love this word feel
free to use it in your casual
conversation
wins you don't vote with your head you
vote with your heart I hope top gun
Maverick wins because it is a really
great screenplay but I just feel like
there's going to be a lot of well we've
got to give a movie like this that kind
of brings the gender back into the
talking here we got to give it something
and this is the most likely thing it's
going to get okay even though we agree
on what's going to win I disagree with
that logic because I don't think the
Academy Awards gets together and has a
big pow-wow meeting and it says let's
all give a woman a nomination I'm
obviously a woman and I don't
necessarily think that's the way that
they vote I think they very much go with
the best script I'm not saying the
academy does get together but I just
think there's this like this this Vibe
there's this this uh sometimes it's an
intangible thing that just sort of a
Groundswell support that could sway
multiple voters one way so let me agree
with women here's the answer
um at least for here today let's go to
animated feature ugh I love this movie I
I mean this is Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio to lose this movie is a
masterpiece and if everything that you
think you know about Pinocchio whether
it's from the obviously that the classic
Disney movie or you know there was
another Pinocchio last year the
Robertson neck is directed that wasn't
very good but when you see this version
and you go this is why it's called
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio it's a
it's a masterpiece it's going to stand
the test of time it's Guillermo's to
lose I was going to say the does the
little Underdog that could Marcel have
any shot here Nikki if there is an
underdog it's none of the ones you
mentioned I think it's turning red it's
a Pixar movie let's not forget that I
thought actually terms of story it was
the best story most original story of
the year I am from Toronto I can relate
to this little girl growing up and
feeling awkward but I thought it was a
brilliant and I think the fact that it
didn't open in theaters maybe doesn't
have the visibility but agree with me
it's a hundred percent Pinocchio made me
weep it should have been nominated for
best picture the only thing that gives
me pause is it underperformed in terms
of the nominations it wasn't nominated
for picture song or score and does that
say that it's not as loved as we think
it is within the academy but imagine
remember this is a certain body of
people that vote for the nominees and
then the entire body votes for animated
everybody can watch it on Netflix if you
haven't caught it sometimes
accessibility helps but it is
unbelievably beautiful and it's also
Guillermo del Toro is already an Academy
Award winner two-time Academy Award
winner for the shape of water best
picture and Best Director so the academy
loves there it is we got some animated
shorts coming your way in just a little
bit but for animated features you're
going to wish upon a star probably want
to make that one Pinocchio Nikki let's
kickoff with you for our next uh topic
which is documentary feature okay this
one is really really tough
um
oh my gosh okay all the beauty in the
Bloodshed is the one that is currently
the front runner for best documentary
feature
um I think a lot of pundits at Gold
Derby are predicting it however I am
picking all the breeds okay this is a
story that is about two brothers in New
Delhi and these birds start falling out
of the sky and it is because of
pollution and it's the effect of that
man has on nature the opening few
minutes of this movie are just a shot of
the birds it is a hundred percent on the
Tomato Meter on Rotten Tomatoes The
Audience score is like 97 or something
like that you can just watch the trailer
and know how incredible it is I think
there's always a surprise in terms of
the categories in this or the
nominations in this category there's
always the obvious ones that get left
out there was a shock when these
nominations were read There were some
obvious ones that were left out and I
think that leaves the field wide open so
I'm choosing all that breeds the movie
that I loved the most was fire of love
which is This Love Story between these
people who investigate volcanoes and the
the footage that they have of these
volcanoes is like absolutely
breathtaking so I'm really sort of like
hope that thing here to use your word
because it's an awesome word so even
though my heart is going you know my
heart is filled with love I I'm gonna go
with the favored with the front runner
here uh which is all the Beauty and the
budget all the Beauty and the Bloodshed
Nikki an impassioned I guess case for
all that breeze but I'm gonna lean with
the current front runner because I'm
nothing wait before you decide
three words
all the freeze my octopus teacher what
about it one in this category
okay okay okay just think about the
narrative the story man loving an animal
before you make that decision I just
wanted to give you one last opportunity
to change your minds
what say you I'm still going all the
videos
for international feature film Scott
there's a big headline here with all
quad on the Western Front is it going to
take this easily oh easily easily this
is the one to beat and it should be
because it is an amazing film nine
Academy Award nominations including best
picture the top one but not best
director and a lot of the crafts
categories as well and this is also the
only film All Quiet on the Western Front
out of the 10 best picture nominees that
is exclusive to a streaming service it
is on Netflix and if you have not
watched it yet you are missing out
because it is my third favorite movie of
2022. it is amazing it's one of the best
picture nominees nine nominations nine
nominations one of the most highly
nominated the baftas I think it was the
most nominated film at the Baptist and
that's when everybody kind of went what
and everybody thought you know Netflix
had a few movies that they had out there
in contention for award season like
Glass Onion and Bardo was another one
and then all of a sudden out of nowhere
the Baptist nominations come out I think
14 nominations and it was just like wait
we all have to watch this
we could be hearing a lot more from
later on in our 2023 Oscars ballot and
just on behalf of all ninth graders out
there thank you for making an updated
film based on the book
we'll move on to original score now
Nikki you get to have the opening Salvo
well a film that was extremely divisive
the most divisive of all the sort of
nominated films this year that was
Babylon but I think it is going to win I
think it's going to actually win in two
categories but I think one of them is is
original score and Justin hurwitz who of
course one for your favorite movie La La
Land uh did the score for this one I
think he is it's hard to say because you
also have John Williams he's 91 years
old 53 nominations uh for the fablemen
so I think there's you know there's love
for him there too but I think when I
think of all the scores that were
nominated right now the only one I can
think of in my head is Babylon I agree I
agree and I agree uh I have Babylon for
one maybe two choices and on my ballot
if you can't convince me on the second
one because I'm on the fence I know what
you're saying I know which one you're
talking about I can't stand absolutely
uh first of all I do love Babylon but it
took me a few viewings to get to that
point Babylon is a whole lot of movie uh
you know whether it is divisible for
course it is divisive but I was never
bored and I just felt like after the
first time I saw it I I need to see this
again like like how do you wrap your
head around maybe I don't want to see it
again I I loved it I mean I like like I
I still have issues with certain things
of it uh but there are there's a whole
lot to actually love about the film
there are scenes that are great you know
the production design the costume design
and the score is amazing the score
absolutely stood out Justin hurwitz who
like you said one for La La Land yeah la
la land uh anytime we get a mentioned
why did I land there for Life original
score goes to Babylon according to our
experts here one of the few rotten
movies that we're going to be talking
about again later on in this show but
for right now we go to the best original
song Scott Mance well hope 15 here I'm
gonna go with Lady Gaga for top gun
Maverick but my head my head is saying
not to not to for RR
everyone loves that song I was at that
screening at the Chinese Theater where
everyone got out the aisles and was
dancing in the aisles and on the front
it was like one of the wildest
screenings that I at the Chinese Theater
that I've ever ever been to uh but uh
rrr is a movie that should have gotten
more love and attention this year's
Academy Awards like why it didn't get
for nominee for best picture I was I was
kind of surprised
um but everyone loves the song so you're
going with your head I've got with my
hands he's going with his head over his
heart yep how about Nikki not too not to
all the way baby I think it's good I
think it's got the passion like when we
talk about a passion
which is amazing that it's gonna beat
Brianna and Lady Gaga in the same
category the nice thing is hopefully
they all perform at the Academy Awards
and we're all winners at that point
Diane Warren though 14 time nominee she
is the Susan Lucci of the Oscars she's
never one she is getting an honorary
Oscar this year but you never know if
the academy might say you know what
let's prove why she's getting an
honorary Oscar and give her one for
Applause because I don't think there's a
true best song this year I think a lot
of it is feeling and personal preference
like you said you love the Lady Gaga but
not too not to not to hopefully
everybody gets up at the Oscars if they
perform and just like in the audience
just like that's the pick and I mean you
talk about you know the performance of
the songs at the ceremony maybe Lady
Gaga shows up and does hold my hand if
not her maybe Hootie and the Blowfish
can sing their version let's go to sound
Nikki we're kicking off with you your
sound is it gonna be another one for All
Quiet on the Western Front
um I'm actually picking top gun Maverick
on this one I I even though Scott has
expressed his love for this movie I am
probably as big a fan of top gun
Maverick if there's hope dicting ever in
the world it's for me with this with
this movie I love it so so much
um but I do think it's a really tough
category but when I look at what has won
in the past I look at like June 1 Ford
versus Ferrari Mad Max big epic movies
with epic sound and you've got the
fighter jets and you can you imagine it
without them you know I mean it was just
incredible and this by the way this used
to be two categories that are getting
now into one so it does change things up
a little bit
um but I think it's got it I mean look
you've got Elvis with the music you've
got other great contenders but it's a
very populous fare here I mean you have
Avatar well over 2 billion you got the
Batman you got Elvis Scott I know your
passions are at War now because you have
top gun Maverick but I know you have an
Infinity for Elvis uh Elvis is great
I've loved the Smoothie made almost 300
million dollars worldwide there are two
movies that brought people back to the
movies in 2022 that were not superhero
movies by the way it was Elvis and top
gun Maverick uh and the problem with
with all choir on the Western Front like
I said it's exclusive to a streaming
service so a lot of people a lot of
Voters probably didn't get the chance to
see that movie on the big screen but
judging by the 1.5 billion dollar take
worldwide of top gun Maverick everybody
saw that movie on the big screen they
probably saw it more than once and like
you pointed out Nikki with all those
other films if there is a film that
screams best sound
absolutely it's not the plane it's the
plywood but that plane makes some old
cool noises yep so let's go to makeup
and hair styling something that I am
very unfamiliar with Scott how about you
you know
if there is one movie where people
associate the film itself with the
makeup it is the whale because
so many people myself included that very
first photo that was released of Brendan
Fraser uh you know all made up I I
thought like oh my God he gained so much
weight and then someone's like
it's a fat suit so but when you're
watching the film when I saw the film
for the first time I'm like looking to
see if I could see any any flaws in the
makeup design and you can't I mean it
that movie makes helps make his
performance maybe a front runner we'll
talk about that when we get the best
actor but I mean again you know Black
Panther and all quiet are also great
contenders here Elvis obviously I mean
sponsor lerman's film he's very very
flashy and you know with Razzle Dazzle
and all that but nope the whale
competitive category here Nikki just
between aquatic creatures because you
have the whale but you also have penguin
in the Batman that was some pretty great
makeup on Colin Farrell I see what you
did there and I see what you're doing
throughout and this is very impressive I
don't know how you're putting these it's
all together you're gonna have to make a
decision on this one because I'm
actually going with Elvis my first gut
reaction was the whale because of the
great prosthetic work but guess what
other movie had great prosthetic work
and other work Elvis and they had a
whole cast of characters not only did
they have to do Austin Butler as Elvis
they had to age him throughout the years
there are some side-by-side comparisons
you cannot tell the difference let's
also remember this is a makeup and hair
category right not just makeup and the
Elvis hair Priscilla Presley through the
years that character and then Colonel
Tom Parker unrecognizable Tom Hanks
great prosthetic work there so I think
the range and the scope of work and the
amount of work that they had to put into
that movie The prosthetic word for
prosthetic work match for match I think
was better on the whale but overall I
think Elvis is more impressive in terms
of what they had to accomplish breaking
news Karen Rotten Tomatoes for the first
time since I had been I have been
joining in on the Oscar ballot show here
you're right it is not just makeup it is
hair and you're talking about more than
one person and going through the years
going through the years
Priscilla because most people do not
Point her out for the first time in the
history of the show I think Scott has
been won over starts off as Austin and
get a chance thank you yes Elvis is
getting the win but Nikki do you think
that you can continue this Elvis train
with costume design well costume design
is another really tough one one that I
went over and over and over but I think
um I think wakanda forever is going to
win for costume design Ruth Carter won
for black panther a couple of years ago
and when I think of costume design as
incredible as Elvis was
um with recreating the costumes
throughout the years it looked identical
to Elvis's costumes uh when I think of
this category what immediately Pops to
my head is the funeral scene with chat
Chadwick Boseman late Chadwick boseman's
Black Panther in all of the white you
also have a lot of new costumes
um with the underwater creatures with
Angela bassett's Regal you know queen
costumes I think just the amount of
costuming they don't always go with you
know a more modern movie in this
category so I'm gonna throw one more
thing out there I used to be in the
fashion business okay no
you know where I'm going with this is it
Jenny beaven is that her name Jenny
Bevan okay
for Mrs Harris goes to Paris the Oscar
voters are older this is a demographic
that they can relate to this is an
underdog pick so if you guys want to go
out on a limb I think this could be a
surprise the biggest surprise of the
night I think this could win for
costuming because she is a three-time
winner okay she won for Cruella the
academy loves her let that sink in
three-time winner for costume design
okay and she created all these Dior
gowns from scratch on a very very
limited budget so just put that in your
brain I still think Ruth is going to win
and she's going to be the only black
person in history to win twice at the
Academy Awards Scott you going to Paris
you're going to wakanda ah so for
costume design I'm actually using the
argument you made for hair and makeup
and also you mentioned uh Mrs Harris
goes to Paris who won for that uh three
times before Jenny Beaver Jenny beaven
okay the costume designer for Elvis is
Catherine Martin Catherine Martin was
also the production designer for Elvis
she has four Academy Awards that she
already won I I believe for a Moulin
Rouge and for The Great Gatsby she won
for production design and costume design
and she's nominated for production
design and costume design and for best
picture because she's a producer on best
on on Elvis so she's three nominations
this year but I just think of all those
films
Elvis is like what what Screams costume
design more than Elvis friggin Presley
Elvis Presley black panther what kind of
forever with originality because the
originality is key in this one and I
think the originality is Black Panther
wakanda forever
I have to make a decision here and this
is or go with Mrs Harris goes to Paris
and Nick's both of us
I actually think the job that Ruthie
Carter did with black panther what kind
of forever was all the more transcended
because we just saw black panther a few
years ago but it felt like an entire
wardrobe change happened in that movie
so I'm gonna go with black panther
wakanda forever as well and that is
going to be the tie breaker here at our
store total get it don't worry I'll let
you tee off with our next category which
is cinematography sorry Scott you can't
Champion top gun Maverick I am not
championing top gun Maverick here even
though
I'm not arguing that should be written
in that was a big snub on Oscar
nomination for cinematography but when I
look at these other five companies tar
Empire of light Elvis and Bardo I think
that this is uh number one with the
bullet is going to All Quiet on the
Western Front uh even on the small
screen watching it at home through
Netflix which is what you should do I
really uh was taken by the
cinematography of of all quiet Nikki
make this short and sweet I concur I
think once you didn't have Avatar and I
thought Avatar should have been
nominated in this category believe it or
not it was a lot of cinematography that
had to be coordinated in a very specific
way but when top gun Maverick which was
the seeming everybody thought it was
going to win let alone not get nominated
when all bets are off when that wasn't
nominated so I'm going through process
of elimination and I I and I just see
all quiet winning it's so heavily
nominated the immersive quality of how
they made you feel you were there this
is the strong I think in all the
categories this is where it's the most
this film is the most competitive so yes
all right let's go to production design
we hinted at it earlier Nikki I'll let
you tear us up here oh oh my gosh this
is the one when I'm voting as a Critics
Choice member I always have the heart
his time with because production design
is something that I truly love and
there's it's always extraordinary
there's so many extraordinary sets but I
am gonna go once again this is the
second choice and I don't know a hundred
percent if it's gonna win two Oscars but
it might but I think Babylon is going to
win for production design when you you
were talking about costumes for
production for uh Babylon but I think
it's the production design that really
stands out when you see first of all the
scene of what Hollywood look like back
in the day and then the silent film set
with all that craziness going on all the
different sets and then the opening
sequence with Margot Robbie and that
dance sequence I I just don't I think
when I look at all these nominees here
that is the one that stands out to me
Elvis I think would be the second
um in sort of in second place for this
but I don't see Elvis winning in the
fact that
it could be a little divisive it's a
little it could be a little devices yeah
in the sense of production design like
when you think of production design do
you picture Elvis or do you picture
costumes performance other other factors
hair and makeup that kind of thing uh
that's a fair argument and this this so
you're going with Babylon I'm going with
Babylon okay so for this category uh
this came down to two choices Elvis or
Babylon and I kept going back and forth
now in my just to to make a choice to
get here on time I went with Elvis but
it was like I was penciling it in with
my number two pencil you have not taken
your finger off the Checker yet no I
haven't and I use the number two pencil
because you know this is the SATs of
oscars like you pointed out
if you're like me taking a test and you
had a Scantron you always pick C when
you didn't know what the answer was who
is your C my C is uh is is Babylon
Hollywood does love rewarding itself
maybe that's gonna happen in production
design category let's move on to film
editing Scott where it's maybe the most
eclectic mix of five movies that came
out in 2022. yep yeah very eclectic
mixed banshees Elvis everything he's
doing his happy dance I'm doing my happy
dance because I'm going with top gun
Maverick I love this movie and boy while
you're watching those those scenes with
the planes and the Jets and all that
stuff
damn damn
d-a-y-u-m damn this is a great film at
the end it's all in the editing it is in
the sounds and then cinematography I'm
sorry it's into best picture uh best
best best actor for Tom Cruise who did
not get nominated but should have this
one's easy film editing for TGM Nikki
you've expressed your love dearly for
this movie as well do you think it takes
the film editing prize they love a big
movie Dune Ford vs Ferrari and Dunkirk
all one in this category but here's a
fun fact that I Hope Academy voters know
800 hours of aerial footage that that
editor had to sift through 800 hours
before he even began putting together
the rest of the film it is done it's a
winner let's move on I think that one's
yeah it's gonna be one hell of a box set
people will pay for it I might be one of
them so I want to stick with you here
Nikki for visual effects because we see
some of the same films that we got with
film editing with cinematography but
this is a more Blockbuster heavy
category then we also have all quad on
the the Western Front could that sneak
up and steal it I love the argument that
you're making here but if Avatar the way
of water doesn't win I will eat this
piece of paper and I will eat it and I
will retire because it's going to win
and that's all I have to say we have our
first paper eating thread okay I will
also eat Nikki's paper okay all right I
hate it it's just a couple different
multiple yeah if there's another lock on
any of these 23 categories 823 it is
visual effects Avatar the way of water
is what visual effects were made for
having said that I think Avatar the way
of water is boring as Sin well that's
not the question Scott it was who's
gonna win visual effects paper for
saying that Scotland see this is why you
watch boring you watch the show because
look a lot of people filling out their
Oscar pool are going to be like oh
visual effects what did I like the best
maybe they don't put Avatar that's your
check mark you got one up on everybody
else who's bringing the chip and dip so
let's go to you Scott mads documentary
short subject you got a feeling on this
one I I do have a feeling in this one
and Nikki the the point you were making
about documentary feature about animals
I think is going to to lead the way for
The Elephant Whisperer to win best
documentary feature it is a beautiful
film about uh an elephant sanctuary in
India that was absolutely breathtaking
and the most most visually stunning and
emotionally moving of the documentary
short subjects so there you go and it's
on Netflix and that's why it's going to
win as well because people can watch it
it's accessible films always aren't
watch stranger at the gate how to
measure a year they're also really great
but yeah I think it's going to be the
Elephant Whisperer I can't wait to try
to watch it on Netflix but then if I see
a baby elephant I just start thinking
Dumbo when he rubs trucks with his Bob
for the last time and it's happening now
let's move on to short film live action
Nikki Novak I'm going with the front
runner and the one that will most likely
win
if you're saying with the French uh
correct French pronunciation and this is
number one this is a Disney plus film
sometimes these short films are aided by
the fact if there's an A-list director
or somebody attached to it that can get
the word out Alfonso Quran is a producer
on this this is the story and look this
is supposed to be said it's not it's a
little ambiguous but when it's set but
it's around World War II about an
orphanage of girls that kind of rebel
against these Catholic nuns and when I
first turned it on I honestly thought it
was shot back then it's that brilliant
and that it does not look modern it
really throws you back to that time but
it sneaks up on you I was actually bored
for the first five minutes and then all
of a sudden these girls are naughty and
you know defiant and it's fantastic and
I think that's going to win uh you know
what when you say the uh Catholic girls
rebelling against the nuns for for a
moment I thought of 1923 uh but this is
not 1923. oh I was going much lighter
with uh Dairy girls okay which is a
wonderful show listen I agree with you
and and I did listen this is another
film that's easy to watch it's on Disney
plus so uh I'm just going to keep the
short and agree
all right so now we move to short film
animated and Scott what are we looking
at this one forget it it's this this
category is over it's the boy the mole
The Fox and the horse What a Beautiful
film not just beautiful animation but
beautiful oh so profound it's so deep
it's so moving it's so inspiring it's
like a it's like a cinematic hug for for
people who are feeling lost in their
lives who feel like they're not worthy
they're not they're not good enough who
just needs someone to say I'm here for
you you matter uh and I it's on Apple TV
Plus
watch it if you've never seen it it's
it's beautiful and it's gonna win I
Concur and again it's you've got you
know you've got Idris Elba Gabriel Byrne
Tom Holland are all voicing characters
people are going to recognize it but I
just have to give a little shout out to
my ear of dicks because when it was
announced at the Academy Awards as a
nominee and what's his drawing a blank
on his name that announced it oh it was
recent Rizza Med announced it and there
was like laughter erupted it made me
curious like is it really about dicks
yeah I think it is and it's about a
woman losing her virginity I'm very much
related to the story and I actually
thought it was really well done but in
terms of the animation and a story that
100 years from now people can refer to
as being Like A Life Lesson cut like
life of pie that kind of thing sure you
will look to this film so boy the mow
the fox and the horse is going to win
yeah just take a look at your valid for
short film animated and enjoy those two
titles and three other very well done
movie titles that's my favorite category
for just the name of a short film lest
we move on now to some of the biggest
prizes of the evening this is why you
watch the whole Oscar ceremony because
you know right around the corner is
going to be the four big ones we kick
off with best actor Nikki you Nikki go
nothing ever in the history of
predicting has made me lose sleep more
than this freaking damn it darn it
category it is a three-way race which I
actually think now might be coming a
two-way Race So this to me is really
between Austin Butler and Brendan Fraser
for the whale I am hope dicting here a
hundred percent because I do think
Brendan has a slight momentum right now
I think he had early momentum and then
he lost it and then when he won the
Critics Choice Award he gave that speech
and a lot of people saw it it was very
emotional
um and I have talked to a lot of people
who were Austin stands and said they
voted for Brendan and I said what do you
mean you're in Austin stand and they
voted for Brendan they're like I thought
it was a contained performance but I am
pitching picking Austin Butler for Elvis
because when you look at what the
academy has awarded in the past for best
actor big performances Eddie Redmayne in
The Theory of Everything a total
transformation
and I think Austin accomplished that he
was a triple threat in this movie he's
saying he danced he acted his heart out
he acted as and it's still funny because
I watched a round table with a bunch of
a lot of the nominees and Brendan Fraser
said to Austin Butler about his
performance in Elvis you didn't Channel
Elvis and Elvis channeled you and I was
like that's what he did yeah Elvis came
through in Austin and when the film
started I was like I'm not sure but by
the end of it I was like this this kid's
gotta win you watched it become Elvis
and you watched Elvis matriculate into
being the Elvis that we knew Scott
you're I know you're an Elvis fan I I
love it look I would be perfectly
thrilled if Austin Butler went so you
make great points that he didn't just
act he had to dance and he had to sing
this is a tough category like you said
three three Front Runners here Austin
Butler and Brendan Fraser and Kyle
Farrell and Kyle Farrell has a spot at
work last year he had four movies
released throughout the year that
exemplified not just his body of work
but all top tier performances in the
Pac-Man and after Yang in 13 lives but
Brenda Fraser is the whale he's the
movie and he literally and figuratively
carried the weight of the world of that
movie on his shoulders and I didn't
think the overall movie was great but I
thought his performance was stellar and
superb for me really it's between Colin
Farrell and and Brendan Fraser wow and
the winner will be the winner is going
to be Brandon Fraser Brendan Fraser so
that was sort of your heart pick and
then slightly more of the head pick was
Austin Butler
no I'm picking Austin Butler I think
Austin Butler will win I think he will
win I think he will Edge it out I want
to remind you the year that Olivia
Coleman beat Glenn Close a very talky
performance versus a total
transformation they don't care about
narrative when you're going down and
you're picking who's going to win
I know when I'm voting I'm not like oh I
didn't give banshees anything so not in
such a big category in such a big
category you're not going to just be
like I'll just give this movie a win
you're gonna pick the best performance
and I think when it comes down to taking
off that ballot overall performance is
going to go to Austin Butler well okay
so here's the thing so
that's where it goes to you Scott the
movie is called Elvis it's called Elvis
and he's playing Elvis and with all that
the busyness of the film going on with
the production design and the editing
and the sound and the Wardrobe and the
music
that he's performance really stood out
so I think for the second time oh my God
Tomatoes history
unprecedented that's the same show
just to show the power of persuasion
that Nikki Novak can provide
uh I just wanted to say I can't help
concurring with you I just want to say
thanks to your persuasive argument thank
you very much
well hopefully Austin wins or else is
going to be a blue Christmas
so I would have I I was I guess I I
would root for Brendan Fraser um because
a lot of people had their revelatory
moments seeing Elvis on The Ed Sullivan
Show for me that was 1992 watching
Encino Man
moving on to the best actress in a lead
role Scott Mass which way are we going
well this is going to be a conversation
unto itself because up until right
before the Oscar nominations I had a a I
had a nominee that I was hoping for and
I had a nominee that I was going like oh
she's probably gonna win the nightly I
was hoping for was Michelle yo for
everything everywhere yes she made
Albany I thought was going to win
because just she gave a fantastic
performance and people are saying it's
performance of her career and it just
might be and she's in every scene of
this two-hour 40-minute film is Kate boy
and Chef for Tar this will be her third
Oscar win while I think her Tara is a
great performance I also
saw her kind of do a very similar role
before Michelle yo has never been
nominated for an Oscar
she is a legend
she has never had a lead role like this
that showcases not just the physicality
of her performance but the emotional
payoff of her performance
you have the chance for Academy voters
to make history by choosing the first
Asian woman to win the Academy Award for
best actress
so between that and the fact that you've
got this this noise that could split the
vote between Cate Blanchett and Andrea
risborough plus the fact that I was hope
for her anyway because I love
Michelle yo and I love this movie and I
think that she deserves to win I'm going
with Michelle yeah Michelle yo is the
answer
is it for Nikki Novak it is not okay I'm
going with Kate Blanchard
um if I was hope dicting I would choose
Michelle yo in a New York minute I
absolutely love her speaking of the word
complimentary she I met her she was so
complimentary lovely she's just an
elegant human being and I think people
who have encountered her in the past
have had a similar experience and that's
why you saw
sort of like so much support behind her
I think she's so beloved in this
business she's transcended time she's
transcended genres and she is just
incredible
but I do believe that Kate Blanchett has
won a lot up into this point I think
when it became obvious to me is when
Michelle yo did not win at the Critics
Choice Awards I know you say it's not a
guild but that made me sort of it
solidified the strength of Kate
Blanchette all the Andrea risborough
stuff I do not think at the end of the
day when people are voting some of them
might not even know about it care about
it I think it's a that part of it is a
wash and I think Cape lunch is still
going to win although nothing would make
me happier than to see Michelle I just
think first of all you have Cate
Blanchard winning that award and unlike
Brandon Fraser who was giving this
really genuinely emotional speech of
graciousness and humility you have Cate
Blanchett saying uh you know I'm sick of
these Tony shows they're like why are we
doing this to each other we shouldn't do
this and by the way if you're going to
do it you should give the Oscar you
should be voting for Andrea raspberry
but I think her overall intention behind
that was to support all actresses and to
say that there is no clear winner but
she mentioned her by name and I just
don't think that out of a ten thousand
Academy voters this that are that's now
up to about it's almost ten thousand
it's close to ten thousand voters you're
telling me that not one person is going
to go back and watch that movie
especially one that is their Duty as an
academy voter to take this stuff very
very seriously and watch to Leslie okay
that's the name of the film that she is
in so it could split the vote is is your
point Mike he's saying that with the
votes costing costing okay
yeah in the academy who is a voter who
is a friend of Andrea reisborough is
still voting for Kate Blanchett all
right so it it this is going to come
down to the wire this is why I'd love to
see the actual scoreboard that we don't
have revealed to us
um I am maybe hope addicting and I
apologize for stealing your word Nikki
but going with Scott mance's pick I'm
gonna go with Michelle yo so that's
going to be on the Rotten Tomatoes
ballot but now the the door is open for
Nikki to Surge ahead we would all
celebrate and pop a bottle luster Lee
let's move on to our final two
categories here we have the best
director the award for directing in a
film for 2022 at the 2023 ceremony Nikki
Novak this is between two okay here we
go and the winner of Best Director is
going to indicate if it's one if it goes
one way if it goes to the Daniels
then the Daniels are going to win for
everything everywhere at Women's which
would they are they're our front runner
at this point that film is a front
runner for best picture I think this is
a two-way race between the Daniels and
Steven Spielberg and if you look back at
the best picture or the best director
winners Martin Scorsese Karen Guillermo
del Toro uh Alejandro inoritu Clint
Eastwood Ron Howard Peter Jackson Robert
zemeckis listen to those names they're
Legends guess who else is a legend
Steven Spielberg is a legend I think he
directed the hell out of that movie I
think it is underrated and how well
directed that movie is it's a master
class it has all the charm
and the last scene in the movie Awkward
scene pays homage to a director that is
highly decorated and award and and won a
lot of Academy Awards and I think the
older voters will also be Charmed by
that fact the Daniels would not surprise
me if they won by the fact that I do
think everything everywhere it's look
it's a new generation of Voters there's
a lot more voters than they used to be
in the academy they've in the past
couple of years gone with more of a
passion vote
um the of the Moment movie everything
everywhere is the of the Moment movie
and I think the Daniels could surprise
people and they could win this but I'm
still going to choose Steven Spielberg I
think he's going to win this award you
make excellent points
and I think that ever since parasite won
best picture Best Director best original
original screenplay like I think the
Daniels will do this year with
everything everywhere and international
feature
that kicked the doors open because you
do have a bigger almost double the well
definitely double the size of the
academy that brought in more
representation more gender bounce more
younger moviegoers and more
International moviegoers or voters
rather
but you're talking about not only Steven
Spielberg you're talking about a movie
that was his story
his personal story on how he became the
most successful filmmaker to walk the
face of this planet you want to know why
he became a filmmaker you want to know
how he did it what inspired him the
hurdles he had to go through watch the
fablements he is the legend I feel like
confusing the goats if he doesn't pay
Stephen Spielberg at this point I'm
going to be shocked do you think you're
at the tetris goat I'm pretty good he is
the filmmaking okay here I care all
right but he is the filmmaking goat now
having said that the Daniels do deserve
to win because they're they they made a
movie that is really far out and it is
an amazing film Amazing a movie that
runs a little long and it's far out and
and sort of threatens to go off the
rails but instead comes back to stick
the landing with an extremely emotional
and Powerful payoff and it is the leader
but I think Spielberg will win all right
so Steven Spielberg I will say though by
the time that this airs if the DGA
winner has come out and it's the Daniels
then the Danielson Daniels then that's
the the indicative Factor you were
looking for for both directing and for
the best picture which is our final
prize of the night we're not actually
giving it out today we're just making
our predictions but here we go with 10
worthy contenders in everyone's eyes
Scott Vance you get to Tee It Up first
are we going to be on the ground we're
going to be way up in the sky this is
the year that the academy set big movies
are back and it doesn't get bigger and
it definitely does not get better than
top gun Maverick now here's the thing
you talk about how the winner of the DGA
will influence who's going to win the
best director Oscar and that winner will
also affect who's going to win the best
picture Oscar well the producers Guild
award the winner of that will also
determine in a very very big way what's
going to win the Oscar for Best Picture
just like the producers Guild the best
picture for the Academy is voted it on a
preferential ballot where they have to
rank the 10 nominees The Producers Guild
does the same thing whereas these other
23 categories it's vote for your Best
winner take all now when it comes to the
front runner everything everywhere all
at once would lead the way with 11
nominations if that movie wins I will be
happy as a pig in mud I love that film
the pieces and I think is it is again
parasite opened the door for a movie
like that for this possibility to even
happen but not everyone loves it it's a
little devices some people love it some
people don't and then you get to a movie
like top gun Maverick which everyone
freaking loves this movie I was careful
everyone loves this movie everyone
everyone loves top gun Maverick it's not
just that it's a great movie the
significance of that film to this
business that business which is made up
of all of these photos people who work
in the business the significance of like
you know last year yeah we gave it to a
streamer we gave it to this little film
Coda but this is what our business is
all about this is why I work this is why
I do what I do I make movies and top gun
Maverick is Top Gun movie it is a movie
with a capital M the second half of that
film I was watching it again for the
tenth time and I just go this movie has
to win this picture and put if people
rank it high enough and enough of them
do and that possibility because of the
preferential ballot that and what I
think Top Gun will win at deserves to
win go top gun Maverick all right so
there's two Miracles highlighted in the
film top gun Maverick could Miracle 3 be
a best picture win Nikki
oh wow did Scott maybe return the favor
and Swoon you towards maybe he didn't oh
and the reason I sigh so deeply is
because nothing in the world would make
me happier than top gun Maverick winning
for best picture because of a lot of
reasons the last time I saw a big big
giant movie that everybody saw and loved
when was Titanic that was the last time
that happened best picture in the 90s so
that was the last time that happened and
everybody loves it you're right but the
consensus I'm getting over and over when
I talk to people voters in different
guilds is that I mention it to them it's
gonna win it's gonna win because I'm
hope dicting it
and they say
like almost like they'd even consider it
and I hear everything everywhere all at
once all at once everywhere everything
every time everywhere I go that is the
movie with the momentum the parasite
type momentum the coda type momentum
going into this final round of awards
season that people talk about over and
over again and so I am going with
everything everywhere all at once for
best picture but I would love to be
wrong a wonderful arguments wager am I
going to go with my heart in my head my
heart is going to say top gun Maverick
it was my favorite movie of 2022 but I
just feel like everything everywhere all
at once is too powerfuls too original is
too much of just a a a spectacle that
you cannot blink and miss any of it that
that is going to be the best picture of
2022 and top gun Maverick we just have
to be happy with its 1.5 billion dollars
gross world record one at this table
everything
one of this table and what an
interesting table it was this year where
Arguments for 11 and some opinion swayed
back and forth there were hopes there
were dreams there were smarts you had a
little bit of everything here and none
of them coming from me your host Mark
Ellis all courtesy of Nikki Novak and
Scott Mance once again thank you all for
joining us and letting your expertise
not just to me or this table but to
everybody watching who's filling out
those Oscar Pals reminder you can go to
rottentomatoes.com or just check out the
description of this vid for your
downloadable printable bracket so you
can win your Oscar pool that's going to
do it for today enjoy the ceremony
wherever you watch it whether it's in
the comfort of your own home you have a
big party it's always fun come Oscar
time not just here in Hollywood but
everywhere around the world everything
everywhere all at once stops and we
watch the Oscars hopefully all the
kerfuffles and the drama will happen on
stage when it's supposed to and not we
don't need to talk about last year
thanks for watching this episode of
after show how to win your Oscars ballot
for Nikki and Scott I'm Mark and we'll
see you next time right here at Rotten
Tomatoes
[Music]
[Applause]